>>Tanya: The ways in which
a multi-tiered system
of support is put to
work in a middle school
or a high school program
looks a little different
than elementary.
>>Ashley: There's not always
as much of a delineation
between tier two and tier
three once you hit secondary,
because the students are taking
so many different classes
and content really
becomes number one.
>>Tanya: Unlike elementary,
where you can pull a small
group out, that's not always
so in high school, because if
you pull a small group out,
they might be missing content.
>>Lynda: So for some students,
it's as simple as providing time
and opportunity to go
meet with the teacher
after school for
additional help.
In some courses, it means our
learning community leaders
who have expertise in special
education, in school psychology,
in reading education, are
pushing into some courses
where there is a
cohort of students
that needs a little
additional support.
>>Tanya: Well, in period
one, I might be in chemistry,
in period two, anatomy and
physiology, period three,
would be tenth grade English.
And I'm providing tier two
along with the teacher.
A lot of push in is built around
helping them with life skills,
organizational skills, study
skills and academic functioning,
giving them strategies
that maybe help them
break down the material.
>>Yeah, so you see
how he's starting here
and then he goes there.
>>Student: Well, it's
two separate flashbacks.
>>Tanya: Correct, yes.
>>Student: It's a
flashback to the call
and a flashback to
his childhood.
>>Tanya: And so essentially, I
go back to school, taking notes.
I'm working with the students,
I know what they're covering.
If I'm living it every day,
I have a really good idea
of who's doing what and then
fostering relationships.
So then it's kind of like,
word of mouth advertising.
If I develop relationships with
my students, they're like, "Oh,
you got to see Doctor Kort.
She helped me with
that senior project,
you've got to go see her."
You see, and so that's
how you get buy in.
>>Ashley: School gets out
at two-oh-five for secondary
and then you have from
two-ten until three
to go receive tier
three instruction
from a learning community
leader, a more on a one
on one basis, or
tier two instruction
from their classroom teacher.
That's what's known
as help sessions.
>>Tanya: Tenth grade is
on Tuesday after school.
Eleventh grade is on
Thursday after school.
And the twelfth grade
team treats their students
like they're in college already,
so they're making
office appointments
or they have established
office hours.
At tenth grade, we have
what's called a comprehensive
help session.
>>Lynda: All of the core
teachers come together
in the same room and it's
kind of a one stop shop.
>>Tanya: I can see some
students came here and they had
to finish maybe something
for anatomy and physiology,
and they moved over into
doing something for English,
or they moved over and they did
something for world history.
Sometimes they like to come
with their friends and then they
like to work together.
Then they want to
finish things up,
they want to ask us questions,
need clarification,
they need help.
>>Lynda: It is becoming a part
of the culture of this school,
which is really exciting,
that kids see the need
and opportunity to go to
their teachers after school
to get additional support.
>>Luke: You get the help
you need specifically
from each teacher.
>>Emily: I get help a
lot from Doctor Kort.
>>Joshua: Normally, I don't
have enough time in class
to do my homework and get really
all this lesson into my head.
>>Emily: Every test
that she's helped me on,
I've had a hundred on.
>>Tanya: Welcome, everybody.
>>Ashley: We meet as a
student success team every four
and a half weeks.
We meet as grade level teams.
The MTSS specialist, the
learning community leader,
the core teachers, the guidance
counselor come to the table
and we talk through
what kids need.
>>Tanya: Yokoa actually
showed up on several
of your lists about concerns.
>>Teacher: He responds very
well to Renee actually.
>>Renee: Maybe I
can influence him.
I don't know.
>>Teacher: Yes.
>>Tanya: And out of the
student success teams,
we are developing lists of
students that we're monitoring
or providing accommodations
and support,
and I'm choosing
classes to push into.
>>Ashley: If a student
is in need
of social emotional support,
typically we'll talk
about that at SST.
Because the problems start
to change as kids get older,
you start having much more
relational and body image stuff.
We have to be very creative
about what type of supports
that we give kids
and who gives them.
>>Teacher: She tries not to
let anyone know, but she knows,
like she can come to my office,
if she's just too overwhelmed.
So she just needs that time to
just talk about it with someone,
or just to get away from
the classroom setting.
>>Lynda: Either counselors or
school psychologists might work
with students who have
some really severe,
specific needs related to
social emotional learning
and we would consider that
a tier three intervention.
>>Renee: When I think having
that individualization,
it's just made it an
incredible difference
in terms of our success rate.
>>Kate: I think it's changed how
we're able to support students.
>>Renee: Out of twenty-five
kids,
twenty-four are now passing
and that's actually a real,
you know, celebration.